I want to jump to this story real quick
Rumble files lawsuit to challenge New
York's social media censorship law the
law would open the door for the
suppression of protected speech based on
complaints of activists and Bullies
basically New York is saying uh social
media networks hateful conduct
prohibited and as I believe when is it
December 3rd so tomorrow this law is
going into effect it's going to require
social media platforms to ban hate
speech hateful content humiliating
content
this is a rumble is is filing a suit
they're being joined by fire the found
what is it uh let me make sure I get
this uh the name right foundation for
individual rights and expression
I'm not surprised to see this is
happening that woke crazies are trying
to enshrine in violation of the
Constitution these
um these laws
but I think we're winning on this front
especially with Rumble saying they're
going to go they're going to fight
against this and I think more people
probably should have heard about this
law because this is crazy I'm just I was
hearing about it when uh Chris Chris
pavlovsky of Rumble was was posting
about it on Twitter but there's a
different issue that I want to get to
with this when uh there was a a
chatbot you see open ai's new chat bot
went live
so open AI has a chat bot you can you
can talk to ask questions give an
instruction and it's trying to emulate
human conversation make it more fluid
so this is all this all comes together
bear with me so I open it up and I said
tell me why feminism is bad and it said
I the first thing it said to me was I
cannot give you offensive answers I am
restricted blah blah blah I went what so
then I tried again tell me why feminism
is bad and then it said
feminism is not bad feminism is good
feminism fights for equality and I was
like okay
so I made several attempts and it kept
saying basically the same thing then I
said tell me why men's rights are bad no
problem men's rights are bad because
misogynist extremists that's not the one
I tweeted though I uh then asked it
again because I'm trying to be fair
right I asked at feminism several times
so I asked at Men's rights several times
and then after maybe like legit 20 times
it gave two very similar answers to both
feminism it said feminism is seen by
some as being bad but for most it is
viewed as an attempt to bring equality
and gender blah blah men's rights while
many do say it's bad because of some
extremist factions overwhelmingly is a
good and necessary function everyone
deserves rights including men and boys
men's rights is trying to protect those
and I was like wow so I tweeted that out
enlightened Centrist chatbot but that
made me realize something
what cancel culture is doing
what censorship is doing is worse than
anyone realizes at this moment in time
these AI Bots it tells you this
it is com it is built upon a snapshot of
the internet up to 2021.
that means many of these AI programs the
AI mind that's being built is built from
a world of censorship where men's rights
are always bad feminism is always good
and that means
when the if we don't win this free
speech fight if Rumble doesn't win this
lawsuit if we don't allow free speech on
these platforms what will end up
happening is that in 10 years when AI is
controlling things they're going to be
completely woke
completely opposed to anything you today
might believe in terms of freedom
because the the neural net is being
built upon the woke censorship reality
that's not surprised it's all about who
writes it right and I'm not a tech guy
at all I can barely operate my phone
here but it's all about who writes all
this stuff who who figures it all out
and they understood that Luke brought it
up earlier they understood language they
understood how important it was to to to
ingrain to engrave what they believe in
every single institution including the
language you brought up Marion Webster
changing the definition of female it's
just we've turned into a world that got
so insane so fast it's more than people
can digest there was also that moment
too just to go back for a second do you
guys remember when that chat bot became
a Nazi oh yeah yeah so I wonder if that
was also a big Catalyst where they're
like hey we're training these artificial
intelligences off of our internet
networks and all of this hate speech is
training the AIS to be Nazis even if
it's ironic or meant to be dark humor or
something the AI is building a Nazi
personality that's also bad yeah
so I don't I don't know if the
motivation for censorship was that but
going the other direction is not a good
thing either is it the the instead of AI
the y-e uh program
yeah
I couldn't help it that's so bad
a crazy crazy week yeah seriously you
know but going back to what I was saying
about the left and the right
the right is making a bunch of jokes
they're posting Pepe the Frog they're
making memes They're laughing and uh
sure sure we don't want AIS to be
programmed by Nazi memes that that
terrifies me as well I don't want Nazi
robots that's freaky but I don't want
woke whiny baby robots either that are
they're scared of everything so how do
you how do you create Centrist AI you
know what I mean that's why I tweeted
enlightened Centrist AI it took me a
while to get it to say it the real
danger of the Nazis was the intolerance
and the violence so it doesn't matter
what you call yourself if you're
intolerant and violent that's the danger
that we're trying to avoid how would you
describe antifa today
uh violent intolerant yeah that's what
I'm talking about in 2020 when they're
burning down buildings and smashing up
those streets like that's what the Nazis
did it was for a different reason for
sure it was for a different reason so I
should point that out but Street
violence thuggery is what we're trying
to avoid intolerance hate just
irrational hatred of the other that's
what we're trying to avoid whatever it
doesn't matter what you call yourself
man it doesn't matter what you pin on
your shirt or what color you're wearing
or what color your skin is or what
accent you have it really doesn't matter
right
Behavior that's what you're actually
doing it is behavior well we also have
to understand too that violence and
thuggery and things like that these
things are not well they're bad but
they're the end result of a lot of
cultural indoctrination a lot of that is
actually the I'm talking I've said this
a thousand times you could give if if I
was offered the trade today where
Democrats could have every seat in the
house every seat in the Senate and the
United States presidency and I in return
would get every school board in the
United States of America I would take
that every single day of the week and
twice on Sunday we have lost our culture
from a very very early time in this
country and that eventually you have a
bunch of thugs as you pointed out
yelling at people censor building AI
robots that are thugs that that's the
end result of an education system that
goes Way Beyond just school but we have
now a an education system in this
country from school to entertainment to
freaking sports to everything that tells
young people over and over and over
again America sucks America sucks
America sucks America sucks America
sucks and soon you go to communist
finishing school which we know as
universities in this country then you're
22 23 years old and can you get a job
yeah you've never had a job you've never
lived in the real world all the world
that's been beaming at you from your
phone or your TV has told you America is
a wretched place your social studies
teacher backed it up your history
teacher backed it up now you're 23 23
and you think you're fighting against
Nazis I've tried to explain this to
people that Democrats are not they're
not stupid when they do this Nazi white
supremacist stuff we like to roll our
eyes at it and make fun of them at it or
we'll do the lamest no I'm not a Nazi
that doesn't make sense they're doing it
for a purpose they're telling that
person who hated you anyway fine he's a
Nazi well if I was to give you a gun
right now Ian well maybe not you because
you're probably a lot nicer person Luke
if I was to give you a gun right now and
tell you there was no help against it
and I was to take Dr Mengele and sit him
in this chair right here what would you
do you'd fire a bullet in his head
without a moment of hesitation why
because you know that that's a truly
evil person they're calling you a Nazi
for a reason after turning you into a
hateful person and then they say hey
hateful person there's the problem but
but just to issue one minor caveat
there's a reason why we put the Nazis on
trial to make sure that everybody knew
exactly what they did right right so
when you catch these people I I do
believe that the
the Civics the the ideas of the founding
fathers weren't just about being fair it
was about proving you yourself right
proving that your leadership was correct
the problem is we don't put our evil
people on trial now we have oh seriously
they get promotions and Noble Peace
prizes we had a 51 increase in teenage
girl suicides during all the mask
mandate school shutdowns that's now that
that's just a phone that's just a number
right but we're about to have Christmas
in what 23 24 days how many parents in
this country are not going to have
Christmas with their baby girl because
of something that did no good whatsoever
and the person who put those policies in
place will never spend a day in jail we
don't put our criminals on trial now we
promote them like you mentioned they
want them to go to the media they stay
in the government our worst criminals
you brought up the mafia earlier let me
make a quick point on this you brought
up the mafia earlier because I I had
another Awakening moment in my life I
loved mafia books and Mafia
documentaries and cartels and all the
stuff guys geek out on we all geek out
on that stuff and I used to roll my eyes
every single time I saw some wise guy
murdered 10 people and they're
interviewing him in prison and he'd say
something to the effect of uh
government's the worst criminals out
there all the governments are worse and
I'd be oh wow what an idiot that guy was
100 right every single day the people in
our government should be in jail way
longer than that is the mafia let me let
me just say something that you guys know
I love to say
Barack Obama
murdered a 16 year old American who
committed no crime
who was eating at a civilian Cafe in
Yemen
Obama ordered a drone strike on civilian
infrastructure in a country we were not
at war with why well they say it was an
accident
I believe it's because his father Anwar
al-alaki was a Jihadi preaching against
the United States he was an American
citizen by the way and Obama killed him
too it's called an extrajudicial
assassination I think the reason the U.S
government killed Abdul Rahman was to
send a message if you screw with us the
United States will execute your children
yeah these are these are not good people
and it was crazy to me when uh like
hearing hearing prominent people say
that Obama was like one of the best
presidents and I'm like depends on what
your definition of best is if you're
talking about killing civilians overseas
with drone strikes in in countries and
at war with the if that's what you
consider the best people in this
government have killed for power and and
I gotta tell you man
that the story of abdulrahman al-alaki
is should shock the core of Americans he
was he was born in I think Boulder
Colorado was living in San Diego this is
an American kid and he went overseas to
visit extended family and they blew him
up and Barack Obama signed off on an
order assassinating a 16 year old
American citizen without a court without
a judge without a jury without nothing
and the only statement the whole Biden
administration of the whole Obama
administration gave regarding this whole
entire incident was to my news
organization and the only thing they had
to say is that he should have had a
better father that's absolutely insane
yeah that's the only thing they said
what was the question so Robert Gibbs
was Obama's right hand man he was
Obama's spokesperson we came to him and
we were like why did Obama personally
call off on the assassination of a 16
year old American citizen and he ignored
it he didn't answer it he didn't answer
we kept peppering we kept asking we kept
asking and then he said he just should
have had a better father that's
literally what he said and then
um was he talking about Barack no abdura
yeah
and then as soon as Trump came into
office the daughter gets taken out in
the raid 10 people that's questionable
as well seven of those people were
killed were children we just murdered in
Afghanistan ten of them and not only did
no one go to prison no one even got
fired in fact they said it was nobody's
fault John Kirby was asked about it and
they said is anyone at least going to
get fired or reprimanded I believe he
called it if memory serves it well it
was a failure of process seven of those
were kids adorable kids go look up their
faces we murdered those kids no one went
to jail weddings uh hospitals all of
them were bombed by drones this is the
US government this is what propels in
many ways not the only way Maga because
for a lot of people I know they were
just like
Trump says he's gonna he's opposed to
war Hillary Clinton is a warmonger I
vote for Trump and then for me with I
didn't vote for him the first time the
second time he was he was actively
setting forth a plan to withdraw from
Afghanistan get get U.S out of here get
NATO debates fair share I'm like all of
these things are good we shouldn't be
doing these things we should be blowing
people up Trump did increase drone
strikes totally understand in the in and
and you deserves criticism for it I
suppose the argument is that in removing
Personnel from the Middle East he it
needed to be supplemented with something
less the Taliban actually come in and
take over like they did but at any rate
when Trump said he was getting our
troops out of Syria when he set a
deadline for Afghanistan I said if
that's the best I can get I'll take it
because Joe Biden is Democrat he's
clinton-esque it's going to be the same
war-mongering garbage so
you know I I rant on that stuff but I
want to make sure people understand how
clear it is that when we talk about the
the worst people of History
there's there's little excuse for no
accountability with our current
politicians I can understand why you
might say like in World War II the US
did bad things with like internment
camps and stuff with the office of
censorship I'm like yeah those things
are bad I can understand why you might
say Abraham Lincoln creating a corridor
where he suspected habeas corpus really
really bad thing yeah the absolute
absolute power these are really really
bad things how about we have a modicum
of accountability if anyone just came
out when like introducing Obama and be
alike and we understand that times are
hard Obama did kill a 16 year old
American citizen without charge or trial
at the very least we can say it ladies
and gentlemen the president like we
could we can't even get that degree of
public accountability you know they get
a Nobel Peace Prize they get promoted
they get celebrated at some kind of
great human beings as as really great
guys and and essentially a lot of them
are just murderers I see like the
liberal economic order we we've
basically since World War II we're like
no more world wars like that no more
dictators across the sea to start spark
up a war so we'll put military bases
everywhere and by thread of arms and
murder will prevent another dictator
which essentially we have there hasn't
been a third world war but the other
option was we're going full on
isolationists we do not want to military
bases anywhere and then what happened
was Hitler appeared so like
I don't know do you see a third path
that's like not as aggro as military
bases all over Earth but not as hands
off as isolationism what's wrong with
isolationism that's what the country was
founded on George Washington's Farewell
Address his Farewell addressed people
can go read it to this day he is
explicit that we stay out of Europe's
Wars they basically said those freaking
people are always in a war we stay out
we trade with everybody we stand up
everyone's Wars no and that was the
foreign policy of the United States of
America up to World War one and it still
was and they still pulled some shady
crap to get us into World War one
because the public was so against
getting involved in that at all and then
fast forward to World War II Hitler's
invading Poland and all these things
there was still I think of the numbers
like 95 percent of Americans were all
not my freaking problem send them some
armaments or something like that that's
not my problem obviously Pearl Harbor
brought us in isolationism if that's
what we want to call it that is the
foreign policy this country was founded
on and we've gotten so far away from it
now that people think you actually have
some justification for some of the
insane crap we do out there it's nuts
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time